[Music]
let's go out to
brooke in salt lake city utah what's up
brooke
hi doing good how are you i'm doing good
you're doing all right
yeah a little little nervous are you
nervous listen i'm not that good at this
there's nothing to be nervous about
i promise you're a better human than i
am at radio so hey what's up how can i
help um
so we have a five-year-old daughter
and a three-year-old son
and some neighbors two boys that are
seven and four and they were
all over at the neighbor's house playing
in the backyard
um when
they wasn't they weren't being
supervised i guess and
they exposed themselves to each other uh
okay was it just like i'll show you if
you show me yours
um yeah so i think i think that's kind
of how it started
um i think the seven-year-old i guess
because i wasn't there i was home with
our baby we have a one-year-old too
okay and wow you've gotta hold on you
got a lot going on
it's utah here
[Laughter]
i love a good utah joke way to go brooke
that's the first utah joke on the show
so well played so you got three
five and under yeah wow okay
so um your five-year-old is playing with
some neighborhood kids
and they end up in somebody's backyard
and there's a seven-year-old a
four-year-old a five-year-old back there
two boys and you're okay
and so to the best you understand
how did that play out so yes i was
so what we gathered was like the
seven-year-old
wanted everyone to just pull their pants
down um
and according to him he because we
talked to our kids afterwards separately
and
his dad said that according to him
they all just pulled their pants down um
and then according to my daughter my
five-year-old she said
that the boys did it you know my
three-year-old and two other boys
but she said no and then when she was
climbing up the slide ladder
uh the samuel pulled her pants down and
um but then i'm not sure
how like the timeline really works but
then when i got there
because i was just taking care of the
baby for a little bit and i was walking
down there to
just kind of join them and when i got
there um
the four-year-old neighbor boy and my
daughter were
hiding in a blanket and i thought that
they were just kind of teasing me so i
went over there and moved the blanket
and
they were both there with their pants
down just sitting by each other
uh okay were they touching each other
i don't think so i mean it kind of just
all happened really fast i think
they were like i think they were
touching themselves okay
um it was was the seven-year-old around
the seven-year-old he he was
in the sandbox with my three-year-old
and he told his dad he was trying to
tell them to stop
okay i think he knew he was gonna get in
trouble for it and he knew what was
happening
gotcha um i don't know if he was
involved in that part at all
okay um and yeah and as soon as
my daughter saw me she just and she's
normally pretty reserved she doesn't
really like
like it wouldn't like in a when like she
gets hurt or something she her reaction
is to
be on her own so we kind of just give
her her space you know like
you know uh in like an emotional
situation but like
she just the second she saw me she just
came into my arms
yeah and was crying you know holding me
and wanted to go home
so what was um you you obviously talked
to
these kids dad right
some yeah yeah how did that conversation
go
i mean we talked a little bit um
i think we could have talked more yeah
because
i just got my kids home and
my husband and i um we're talking to my
daughter he kind of
she wanted to be with dad so she he kind
of talked to her and got her to
kind of open up she was really worried
about
telling talking to us and so but he you
know
kind of gave her the confidence to tell
us you know
whatever that she was okay good for him
and
yeah he's a pretty good dad yeah um
but and then yeah and then i you know
converse with the neighbor
um over the phone just kind of figuring
out what his kids were telling him
um but there really hasn't been like
too much involvement from their side how
long ago did that happen this happened
um it's it's been a little while it's
sorry i guess i feel a little bit guilty
about how it's been about a month okay
i mean it don't go to straight to guilt
okay you've got a lot going on
um so here's the the big picture thing
is this four-year-olds and
five-year-olds are curious
right so i'm not gonna lose my mind i'm
not gonna get angry
i'm not gonna blow a gasket or anything
like that right
um it sounds like y'all did
a really great job of talking to her
and when both your kids when you got
them home your son and your daughter and
talk to talking to him
just to kind of get cut to the chase
here i there's a great book called some
parts are not for sharing
and there's important conversations to
have with
four five six seven year olds about
really
four five and six three four and five
about
you know who's allowed to see you which
is mom and dad and the doctor and that's
it
always and forever end of sentence right
and unless you know there's a
grandparent that's doing some caretaking
and then then there's a conversation
that happens and then once a kid gets to
be four or five
we're asking um can i come
do you need help with you know wiping do
you need help with in the shower
not just bursting in and saying hey i
get to be right i want to begin to teach
my kid
that they have autonomy over their
bodies at a really really young age
but the stepping back the fact that this
happened i don't like that
seven-year-old kid there
there's something about that that whole
thing feel if you were to call me and
say hey
my neighborhood boy is a four-year-old
and my daughter's
four or five and they were just standing
there showing each other that
i wouldn't that would make me raise my
eyebrows they're just kids
having a seven-year-old there
potentially egging it on
and knowing a little bit more and um
getting people to do things they didn't
want to do that's the part that i got a
real problem with
um so here's what i would do if i'm you
number one i would
ask um their these kids parents to come
over to your house so it's in your
it's in your kingdom for lack of better
terms right it's on your turf
and let them know hey we're i don't feel
comfortable with our kids playing with
your kids
and um i'm gonna ask you guys respect
that boundary okay
regardless of how it happened i'm not
comfortable with it and this is gonna be
a hard conversation and make your street
weird
but your allegiance isn't not to the
neighbors down the street your
allegiances to your two little kids
okay yeah the balance here is that your
daughter's gonna feel like she lost some
friends and she did something bad
yeah does that make sense and so it's a
real careful and that's why i love this
book you read it with them
and you're able to look somebody else
wrote this and i think it's with um
i think dr jennings told me it has
turtles and
fish or something i mean it's a very it
steps away from
from the situation right and so it lets
a kid see it happening
um and because a seven-year-old was
involved
because your daughter says i think that
boy pulled my pants down
i want them to understand at the age of
five
that if somebody puts their hands on me
if i'm assaulted which is what that is
that mommy and daddy are gonna stand up
tall on my behalf
yeah and so what i would do is um
probably at least do one session with a
play therapist in your
in your local area if not to and to say
hey this happened
um can you help all of us with the touch
conversation
potentially get to the bottom of is
there anything super nefarious here
and then help give us some guidance as a
third party
with the whole family on how we can not
put
let our kid know how serious this is but
not shame them in the process and it's
just gonna be a delicate conversation
it sounds like and again you and i have
known each other for like three and a
half minutes right
yeah the fact that when she got home she
said i want to talk to daddy
and that tells me you guys are great
parents
and that you guys have set up an
environment where it's not
a scary thing to talk to mom or dad is
that fair
yeah i think one thing that was kind of
a little soul-crushing i guess
um was as you know
as dad was trying to kind of just
ease into the conversation she
told which i don't know why um but she
told him
you know that we're not gonna love her
and so that's i think yeah that is i
think that the advice you've given is
really helpful but i think that's like
the biggest
fear is i don't i don't want to
some sort of i feel like it can go bad
two ways either
you know yeah i go play with the kids
and now it's mom and dad saying
hey doesn't matter what people do to you
mom and dad give permission for anything
to happen
sure or her or like yeah i guess
you know like i don't want her to think
that like yeah we
if we see anything bad you do then we
don't love you
yeah so i i don't ever want to equate
accountability and safety with i don't
love you
in fact i want you to teach your
daughter the opposite of that
so i've said it on the show before and
my kids now they're old enough they roll
their eyes
my kids are 11 and 5. and i've got a
five-year-old daughter so i'm trying to
think through this in real time with
you okay yeah if i ask my parents
i mean i'm sorry if i ask my kids what's
dad's one job they roll their eyes
like to keep us safe and i've been
telling them that since they were zero
okay precisely for these moments
because something's gonna come up
multiple times over and i'm gonna tell
my daughter
hey a boy put his hands on you
and only mom and only dad and only the
doctor are allowed to touch your bathing
suit parts
and he did that and that is not okay
what's my one job and she'll go huh keep
me safe and also
say exactly and mom and dad will not let
you
be around people that are going to hurt
you or take advantage of you
and i want you to know that mom and dad
wouldn't talk to their daddy
because they should not be doing that
either and those that's is
as complex as the conversation needs to
be but i want her to know
that yes if somebody does something mom
and dad are there
when she's a child especially
and she may interpret it like oh man i
told mom this happened and now i can't
have any fun
that's going to fall on you guys right
so that there's not a gap that now she's
not just sitting in the backyard
you know drawing a circle with a stick
maybe that's cool my kids like to do
that so i don't know
that she doesn't feel punished that she
doesn't feel that she's in trouble
as much as she's now knows that she is
safe
because mom and dad are on her side does
that make sense
yeah and that's a thin careful line to
walk
um and when you go to play therapy play
therapist it's a blast
they have a blast it's just a room full
of all this chaos and fun
if you get a dud it's not it's not that
great
the ones i've seen are really incredible
and kids
speak in play and so they talk that way
and so they'll
a good play therapist after a session or
two will be able to tell you exactly
what happened or very close to what
happened
and be able to walk alongside you guys
um
when she told you this is my last
question for you when she told you
i was i'm afraid y'all aren't going to
love me what was the response
um that she said it to to
my husband um
but we did talk about it together
because
you know we he came with her to me to
as we all talked to the whole family and
he told me that you know reagan was
concerned that
uh that she's concerned that we
wouldn't love her and and he said that
you know
that's never the case and and so we just
kind of
had a little hug puddle and told her
that we love her so much and she's
you know our very first baby and
we are always going to love her and
she's always our kid and
just kind of milked just how much we
love her
and so you've you've created a platform
for it she knows this by the way
um tell her that every single day
make sure your husband tells you that
every single day make sure that's a
language you'll speak but more
importantly make sure that you show her
that every single day
right especially with a five-year-old
that's if
she's into it that's a lot of hugs
that's a lot of eye contact that's a lot
of touching
on the face letting you know that she's
safe that she's
of value that you love her and more
importantly that you will intervene
you will get involved okay so grateful
that you called
um this is a super common thing and so
it's this fine
line between uh and there's so many
variables too it's a fine line between
oh no and i don't ever want to steal
curiosity for i want my kids to be
curious about everything forever
i want to i want to teach them that and
i don't want them to find themselves in
a backyard with two or three boys
being coerced and doing something she
doesn't want to do i
definitely don't want her climbing up on
something and having some boy who's
bigger and older than her
take advantage of her um i don't want
her in an unsafe situation where she's
under a blanket with some
other kid and so it's a it's that fine
balance between a love you
that's not safe here is what safe is
we're going to read this book together
we're going to go
play with this cool doctor down the
street we're going to do these things
and never i will go to the ends of the
earth because i love you so much
and you can't go play with those boys
anymore period
and you and your husband are going to
demonstrate that by having a hard
conversation with them too
all of this stuff adds an ethos and at
home to my mom and dad got my back
even when it's hard and messy and ugly
and screwy and scary they got my back
and i got a five-year-old too ugh having
kids man
thank you so much for that call brooke